Oh, hi, everyone. Um, thanks for attending
my session today.
I really appreciate it. I know this is getting at the end
of a kind of a long and busy week, so I
appreciate you taking the time, uh, to come and,
and watch this presentation today.
Um, my name is Richard Nichol. I'm a
product solutions architect for NetApp.
Um, I've been working with NetApp for about 14
years now.
Um, with about half that time, I've been working, um,
in our cloud-based products.
And I've been working with FSX for ONTAP
really since its inception, right? Since it
was an idea
between ADbus and NetApp. So I've been involved with it
for a very long time.
And I've been working with the EBS, um, as
part of Early Access at the beginning of this year.
And so today, I'm going to talk to you about
how you can leverage FSX for ONTAP to
help optimize the storage cost for
your Amazon Elastic VMware deployments.
Um, so from agenda from a very high level,
um, we're gonna start by, I just want a level set
on what, you know, EBS is. It's a relatively
new service. So, you know, what are the main,
you know, functions and features of it. Um,
and then I'm gonna kind of do a similar thing for
FSX for OnTap. I'm gonna talk about, you
know, what it is, you know, everybody's not always super familiar
with it, um,
and, you know, what are its main features and how
those features work with EBS, right?
And what are the advantages of those features, and
then how do those two services actually end
up playing together as well.
Um, I also. So we'll then get into kind of like
3 main pillars, you know, how you can lower the
total cost of ownership, and a lot of that's around
how you can decouple compute from storage.
Um, I'm gonna talk about how you can improve
your SLAs for trying to protect your VMs
that are running, um, in the EBS environment.
Um, and then I'll get into like, you know, how you can
operate on-prem and in
cloud
using the same ways and, and functions and
ways that you've operated there, you're going to take
that same thing and operate it in the cloud. And I
will show you how like FSSONTA can help facilitate
that. Um.
And so then, um, I'm gonna get to really one that
I'm really, uh, excited about, uh, a
disaster recovery scenario
that leverages FSX for ONTAP, and there's some
new capabilities with FSX for ONTAP that makes
that a very compelling,
uh, use case for, um, kind of helping you
keep a minimum footprint for those types of,
uh, uh. Scenarios.
And then finally, I'm gonna get into a tool called
Workload Factory.
Uh, this is a free tool. I'll probably mentioned that multiple times,
and this is one that's gonna help you plan and migrate,
um, your workloads um from VMware
and operate them in uh ADOS
with EBS and FSXONTAP as, as
the storage.
Um, so I'm gonna start, um, with the Elastic,
uh, you know, Amazon Elastic VMware Service,
you know, talk about it at the highest levels. And
you can think about it at the highest levels, right? It
is just the fastest and easiest way
to take your VMware environments and
operate them efficiently and
with the same way in the cloud. So what you're basically doing is you're
taking You know, one of the main tenets for
EBS when it was created is that
we want to give you full control of
the environment in the cloud. So however you're operating,
you know, with your VCF stack, right, you're basically taking that
same VCF stack, and you're taking it up
to the cloud and operating it in a similar
way. And so, um,
so that's when, and then once you get up into the cloud, then you
have the access to
Amazon services, which, which is another great advantage
of EBS and a good way of getting, you know,
a lot of stuff that's on-prem and getting into the cloud
and get all of the advantages of the cloud.
And then so it's about, you know,
control, and then also choice. How do you want to then
handle that once you're up there. And that's the way you
can either manage it all yourself
or you can bring in a partner as well. And
so I'll talk a little bit more about that, um, on
the next slide.
So you can be customer managed, right? If
you have all the tech technical expertise
in-house, you know how to do migrations,
you know how to maybe set up HCX, you
know how to, um,
you know, run your day to day at ESXI
host, right? All those types of things, and you're comfortable with that,
and you have the technical know-how,
great, you can do it all yourself. You don't need
anybody else. But, uh, you know, ADMS
has met with a lot of partners who say, hey,
there's a lot of customers that maybe they need help migrating
up, right? Or maybe they just need some help
with automation. Right? So there's partners
that have been involved with EBS since
it was early access as well.
So it really is giving you that choice.
Maybe you don't want to get
uh a text in the middle of the night that there's a problem
with this ESXi hosts, right?
So partners can help, you know, manage, they can help you
migrate, they can meet you wherever you are, whatever
your needs are. So really the, the takeaway
here, right, is that Amazon, right, has given
you complete
choice, right, in, in how you want to operate
this VMware environment once you have it up and running
in the cloud.
Um,
you know, 11 more step back, right, you know, or,
or, or down, I guess, um, this is showing,
hey, what are we talking about here with EBS, right? You've
got an on-premises system,
and you've got your VCF stack, as I said before, you know,
you have your vSphere clients,
you have, um,
your, your NSX manager, you've got,
uh, your, your VSAN, right? And you've got all that
on-prem. And so basically you're taking that and you're
moving it into the cloud, you're operating it
exactly the same way. All those, you know, VCF
components are also there in the cloud.
Um. And there's multiple reasons why
you might be doing this, right? Um,
maybe you're shutting down, an existing data
center, right? For that existing data center, you
want to evacuate it, you're just migrating
this all up in the cloud, and you just wanna be there quick and
you have the expertise and you wanna operate it exactly
the same way.
It could be also that you're just extending
your data center. Maybe you are running out of
space. And may, or maybe you're like,
I'm not quite ready to go all the way into
the cloud, right? I wanna do dev test so I
can just move up some dev test workloads, get
comfortable with the cloud, right, and then, and then move from there.
Maybe it's a disaster recovery. You got your on-prem
and you don't wanna set up a whole other data center just for
disaster recovery, right? That's another option.
Or maybe this is just your first
step in, um, and I'm gonna talk more about
the disaster recovery because I think, uh, FSI for OnTap's
a really neat use case around that.
And then, um, maybe you're just, this is your first
step of modernization. You bring up some apps and
then you start tying. And so the whole key here, right? The other
whole half of this first picture is that you
tie into all those Amazon services.
Maybe you want to
do the first step of modernization, take an app up into
the cloud and, and run, um, Bedrock on
it, right? So there's, you know, a plethora
of, of Amazon services out there, right? So you're, you're
taking that first step into getting
access to all those services.
So just one more step down, right, on
what EBS is. Um,
the first thing is that it's an automated deployment,
right? So it's really, really easy to
use. It's really, really easy to get started with.
Um, so you can do it either through the console
or the API
and you really don't have to provide
a lot of information. You say, OK,
I need, I need to deploy it in a VPC, right? So
you're gonna supply a VPC.
You need some ESXi hosts, so you can supply
your EC2 instances. Um, you're gonna
supply. Um, your licensing
or your, or your subscription, your VCF subscription,
right? You're gonna have to apply that right when you deploy it.
Um, and you have to set some sitter ranges. There's
some, essentially, you know, the EBS is taking
the NSS's networking, and it's like
kind of emulating it. So there's some private VLANs, you have
to set up some sitters for that.
Um, once you've defined all that,
then you click go.
And in about 3 hours, you have a
completely functional
VCF stack running in the cloud. It's
pretty amazing, really. And it's using, it's, it's,
you see here, it's using Cloud Builder to do it, right?
Um, and so,
again, you, once you're done, then you have
an NSX manager. You have a, a,
a vSphere client, you have an SCDC
manager. And you have,
um, and it says here you have full control, right?
You get
with ADbus Secrets Manager, you get
access to
the username and a password for all those services.
You can even get to the ESXI
host, root ESXI host, right? So
when we say full control, it really is full
control when you're coming into the cloud. Um,
for right now, for the first pass right now, um,
there's i4I metal instances is what's
supported, right?
There are plans to add other metal instances,
um, in the future. Um, it will give you different, you
know, price points, different performance, different storage,
you know, footprints. And, so that is coming. But
for right now, you know, um, that's what it is,
is I4I, uh, metal. And when you
do that deployment right now, again, it's also
VCF 5.2.1. Um, there's
obviously plans for VCF 9, so both
of those things are going to be coming, but for right now, that's what
you get. And you do have to supply
your own licensing, right? So you have to supply your, your
VCF, uh, subscription.
And you got to make sure that the cores, that the VCF
subscription that you have has enough cores
for the
four-node minimum
I4I metal deployment. So right now it's a
4-node minimum.
So. Again, right, you're bringing all
this up. And we're talking about the consumption, um,
that's, you know,
the consumption of your EC2 host is really
what that's talking about there, right? Do you want to do on-demand?
Do you want to do one year? Do you want to do 3-year?
Obviously, you do 3-year, your price will come down,
um, significantly,
but, you know, you just gotta make sure you make that commitment or
not. Um, and then also,
you know, obviously when you do this deployment, at the end of that
deployment,
everything's there, you've got access to everything. You
do get VSAN storage, you know, by default,
right? The, the I4I metals come with some
instances stores that become the VSAN, and so you have
storage there with you. And that's actually where
the VMs are deployed, right? The VMs are deployed, the,
the SEC manager and the vSphere
client, all those things are deployed onto the VSAN.
But you also then have the option of
adding on FSX for ONTAP as
additional storage.
And that's where I'm gonna spend most of my time.
And so at the highest level here, right,
um, I think a really critical thing here, right, is that
Amazon FSX for ONTA
is the only ADS native storage
service, right, that's been certified for Amazon EBS.
So if you wanted to do, go native, right, with
your storage on Amazon EBS, it's gonna be FSX
for ONTAP.
Um, and so now really,
you know, what is FSX for ONTAP? I'm gonna spend a little bit
of time here because it can sometimes
be a little confusing for people because, you know,
it has ONTAP in the name or, and, um, and, and
has NetApp in the name as well, right? But it
is a fully managed AWS storage
service. Um, and it sits there next to
S3, EBS EFS, right?
It falls there. It sits underneath the
FSX, like the file system umbrella,
right? But it is a fully managed
AWS
storage service.
But what's unique about it? What is unique, you know, why, why
do they bring it in? It's because it's able
to bring enterprise grade features
to your, to your storage in the
cloud. And what do I mean by that? What kind of enterprise
grade features?
Accessibility. We support both file,
block, and object storage. And
for, you know, lots of times, I, I kind of always
highlight block because
we are, we're underneath the file system, right? FSX
file system, right? And people think of ONTA. Lots of times
people think of NFS. SMB,
but we also support Block. And about 30% of
the deployments of FSXONTAP
are leveraging Block, lots of times
for things like self-managed databases and those types
of things. So we do do Block as well.
Beyond B block, we also support multi-protocol
access. And that, what we mean by that is
one set of data, right?
You can access it with NFS and SMB
and lots of times customers have those requirements, right, on-prem
as well, right? And also
S3, and I, I'd be remiss if I didn't really
call that. That one out because,
um, that is, was just announced,
right, this week, um, at the, uh,
at the keynote, right?
That FSX or ONTA
can be an endpoint to all these different
now ADS services that leverage S3,
like Bedrock,
Redshift, right? All of those now. So
now you can have one set of data
and do like, you know, uh, uh,
AI type of stuff on that same set of data. Now,
that's not what this talk is about, but I did just wanna
make sure I highlighted, right, that that new announcement
just came out.
Um, so then resiliency and protection, um,
high availability. Essentially,
there's two nodes for an FSX OONTAP system,
and they're replicating data back and forth,
and so that your data is always available when you need
it. And really the superpower of
ONTAP, right, is snapshots. So
that you always have a local copy of your data. And why
do I say superpower? Because
they are pointer-based, they are instantaneous.
They, um, only do deltas, and
they're really the bedrock to use the,
the AI term. They're the bedrock of what
ONTAP has been built on for 30 years, and we're taking
that same type of
really enterprise grade storage functionality
that a lot of the other functionality that's in ONTAP is
based on snapshots as well. So, um, and
I'll show you later on, like, like, why that's
important as well for this particular deployment,
uh, for use with EBS and FSXONTAP.
Data security. This one's always, always
super important in the cloud.
Um, it's, you know, FSX FONTA
has, is secured from the bottom up, right? If you
start at the bottom of the stack,
data at rest is encrypted with
KMS or a customer KMS key.
Um, if you go up a level from that stack.
We can do uh data in transit. We
can encrypt with SMB encryption,
NFS with Kerberos. We also support
IPSec, right? Um,
then we also integrate with Active Directory, so
you have only the right people can talk to the files,
right, um, for, for SMB and NFS.
And then beyond that, even, right, then we also
have, um, immutable storage options.
Um, what I mean by that is that you can say, hey,
once this data has been written, it cannot be
deleted for a certain number of time. And we support
compliance.
Immutable storage, which means nobody
can change it. Not even, not even AWS. If you
call into a support ticket and you've put a lock
on that data for some certain period of time,
not even AWS, uh, uh,
administrators can delete it.
So it really is that, that level of protection. And
then one step on top of that even
is the malware protection.
There's a feature called autonomous ransomware
protection, um, that's built into the storage
layer. There's no external client that does this,
that looks for entropy changes or
looks for, uh, file extension changes.
And when it does that, it takes one of those immutable
snapshots instantaneously. So you can
make sure you stop it. Track. And not only is it taking that snapshot
with the version that's coming out really soon,
it's actually taking us a couple of snapshots right before that
as well, so that you can
go back in time before that you even noticed
that the um attack was happening.
So again, we're giving you that kind of capability,
um, with this, this enterprise grade.
Here's a big one, right? Always important, price and
performance, um, data footprint reduction,
FSX for RTA supports deduplication.
Compaction, compression, right? Those are
very important, uh, things to keep that storage
footprint, right, to a minimal amount.
It also supports data tiering,
where essentially data tiering is, um, we have an
SSD layer or an FSXONTA, but if we
notice that there are blocks that are cold,
then it will tear those blocks off
into the capacity tier. And so that can also
help reduce, um, you know, your overall
cost for, for running, uh, that storage.
And, and this can also, it'll come up again when we look at,
uh, the disaster recovery, uh, scenario.
Um, and then finally,
we can easily replicate data
using SnapMirror, which is again a snapshot-based thing to
other regions. And we also support a
feature called Flex clones. Flex clones are
really important because
they are, again, they're leveraging snapshots. They're,
so that you can create an instant
copy of your data.
And then, um, and since we're pointer-based,
um, any new rights are
the only thing that are saved, right? So it makes it a very
way inefficient. I'll point to later how that
can play in some of the, uh, VMware,
uh, flows later.
OK. So that's um that's
the uh FSX RONTAP.
So like, so now I said, OK, we got
FSX FONTAP and we have EBS. How
do these two
services play together? Well, we have two options, right?
Um, one is a data store, a supplemental
data store. And for that, as I said before, right,
we support multiple protocols. So we support NFS
data stores, and we support ISCSI data stores,
and also for Block now, we support NVME
data stores, right? So it's really whichever
one you're more comfortable with, right? If you've been
using NFS data stores on-prem.
Use it the same way in the cloud. If you've been using Block
and you're familiar with that,
then bring Block into the cloud, right? So both of those,
you have the options of, of, of whatever data
store you want. The other thing, right, that
we do, if you're not talking about external data store
itself, is that we can be guest attached
storage. So we're just essentially,
maybe you have some type of shared
uh storage requirement, right? And
multiple VEMs need to access that data,
right? And so we can be guest
mounts and we support NFS and SMB
as guest mounts to your VMs
that are running inside of EVS.
So, um, a little bit of an architectural picture.
Um, I won't super deep dive, but just at the
highest level, right? If you look at this picture,
what do you see? You see that the EVS deployment,
right, has an overlay network that's kind of, uh, shown
there. It's deployed into
your VPC, the customer VPC, right?
There's no shadow VPC, it goes right in
there. And what else is deployed
into that exact same VPC?
FSX RONTAP.
Now, you see there's, um, you see
there's a couple of like uh ENI's there. That's just
the way FSX RONTAP plugs into any, it's
a, it's a managed service. That's just the way it plugs in anytime
you're gonna deploy FSX for ONTAP.
So the, the way then to connect
this up as a data store is you set up a
NFS, for example, an NFS file
server, right,
on your FSX for RONTAP system.
You go into the vSphere
client that was deployed.
And you go through the steps to say,
set up a data store. All you do is choose
the IP address
of the of the NFS server that you set up
on FSX for OnTap.
Like I, I wrote the guide for how to, how to set
this up.
It was boring, right? I didn't have anything to
write. I was like, do what you've always done, right? It's the
exact same steps. The only thing, oh yeah, by the
way, we do connect up with
an ENI and you got to update the
security group on that ENI to make sure that the
NFS ports are open.
That's it. That's the only unique thing I had to do. Other than that, it's
the same way you have a data store, right? So the,
so then my, my, my takeaway from this is like
you set up a, a NFS server
and you connect it the same way that you've, that you've
always done it.
So very simple to, to hook up. Oh,
and one other thing I forgot to mention is that, so I have it
shown here, right, in the same VPC. You obviously
don't have to put your FSX RONTAP system in the
same VPC, right, as your,
as your um EVS. You could put it into a
separate VPC and do like VPC
pairing.
Technically, you could do Transit Gateway, but
I would not recommend Transit Gateway for a, for a data
store, uh, in general.
So that's one option, right?
The second option was the other one that I mentioned, you know,
guest attached storage, right? And for that,
it's similar, right? The, you still have the NI,
you still can be deployed in the same VPC,
but we're attaching to the VMs themselves
that are running inside your EVS like overlay
network, right? So you have your VMs that are up
and running there, and you're gonna mount those VMs.
Now, the other thing that's slightly different. Here
right before with the, with the data stores were coming
directly from the NSXi hosts.
With, uh, a guest mount,
there is a virtual router, and that's, it's
shown in the picture here is like an NSX Edge router,
right? Um, and so essentially, the,
the data does have to be moved right between the, the
kind of overlay network to the underlay network.
But the nice thing is, is that when you do that deployment.
Amazon, right, is part of that cloud builder, it does
all of that for you, right? And
if you go into your NSX and you want to add a new
network segment,
there's BGP on that virtual router.
It's gonna automatically update your ADBS
route tables to be able to get to that.
So it makes it super, super easy to do.
Not a lot of, hey, here's the special things that I have to
do to make this work. Um, and again, the
only thing you have to do is make sure that you have your ports open.
You want to set up NFS, you log into your VM
and you do mount.
Nothing more than mount, right? As long as that, those
ports are open, you got it up and running. Now here's
the other important thing I want to say here is, right? Remember we
talked about multi-protocol, right?
This is this scenario where lots of customers, if
they have multi-protocol requirements, right?
This is where they might want to set up some shared data store,
and you can have that one set of data. Your VM, this
NEDS can access that data, and your
SMB, uh, Linux, I mean, sorry,
Windows client can also access that same
data, right? So it's really giving you complete control
there. So
now we're gonna get into like, you know, some of this cost optimization.
Um, you know, we're gonna talk about several ways, right,
that, that the, uh, NFS, I'm sorry, the
FSSONTAP can help with some
different areas of, of, of operating your
environment. One is cost optimization.
And it's basically the ability to decouple, compute
and storage,
because for the, uh, ESXI host
right they're deployed right now with the I4I metal, you get
storage and compute together.
And so we're gonna help decouple that to, to
reduce your overall cost.
Um, next is the, if you're,
you need to do VM backups, right, we can help you
improve the performance and reliability of doing those backups,
making sure that you're meeting your SLAs.
And then finally,
improve operational excellence, like take everything that
you've been doing on-prem
and replicate that the same way and doing
it in the cloud.
So we're gonna start with lowering the total cost of ownership.
Um, one of the things about FSXONTAP
is it's very flexible. Um, and
so there's multiple storage types and performance
options. So let's just say that you were setting
up your, you know, your data store, and
at some point, you know, you had.
Um, uh, you know, some VMs are running there, but I also
need to add some more VMs that have a
higher performance need. You can simply
change the throughput on your FSX
RONTAP system.
And as I said before, it's an HA pair, right? So
it's, um, it's, uh, an active passive.
And so if you want to change the SKU
and add more performance to your storage.
It does it non-destructively because it does automatic
failovers. So you never lose access to
your data while you're doing those. And so you can scale up and
scale down your performance needs as you need
them, right? You can scale up your IOPs that
are needed for it, right? So it really gives you that, that
full ability to, to handle
whatever you need at the time that you need it.
Another one is the built-in storage efficiencies.
This one cannot be overlooked. Obviously, this, you know, I
said before, the deduplication, the compression and compaction.
With VDI workloads and deduplication, we
can save up to like 70%
on your, on your, uh, footprint, right? So that's,
can be a significant cost savings.
So, so definitely, you know, that those built-in storage efficiencies
are very important.
And finally, like we can decouple the storage from compute.
I've got a few slides that kind of, you know,
animate and show this, uh, in action.
So for a storage scaling example, um,
this is the 4-node minimum I was talking about before,
right? For,
uh, I4I metals, you're getting, you know, 30
terabytes of storage. All that's not usable,
but 30 tibobytes of storage, um, per,
uh, ESXihost, you know, 64, uh,
CPUs.
And you're, you're running along just fine, right?
You're happy with everything. And then you know what,
I need a little bit more storage, right? I need 40
terabytes more storage.
So what's the solution, right?
If you don't, if you're just having that, you know, tightly
coupled, um, you know, hyperconverged
CPU and storage coming in together, you have
to add 2 more ESXi hosts,
2 more ipori metal just to get that 40
tabbytes more of storage.
So that's unnecessary compute cost, right? You're not, you
didn't really need that extra compute.
So what we can do is bring in the 40 terabytes
on a supplemental data store from FSX
for ONTAP.
And, and not only are we bringing in the 40 tibobytes,
right? We're also doing de-dupe compression,
all those types of storage efficiency features. So
maybe you don't even need 40 tibobytes, right? So
it just depends on, on, on your, on your workload
and your use case.
So what I want to show here with this graph, right, is essentially,
right, that advantage that we bring in, right? As
your storage and your, your EBS environment
grows, right? That's gonna grow more and more, right?
So you're gonna have, you're gonna get more and more value out
of, you know, scaling those things
independently. Now, obviously this is, has some
type, this, you know, this chart is built in with some
assumptions about how much compute
I need, how much storage I need for how much compute. But
you can see, you know, as you really grow, you're gonna be
saved up in the millions of dollars.
The other kind of important thing on this particular
slide is that what we're showing for that
cost is just the cost by not
adding unnecessary ESXi
hosts. But
by not adding unnecessary ESXi
hosts, you're also reducing your core count.
The VCF subscriptions are tied to
core count. So we don't, we don't know what those numbers
are because they're different for every customer,
but you're actually also saving on your subscription
at the same time. So it can be very powerful.
All right. So that's, you know, that
decoupling is compute story is pretty straightforward
story, right? Um, and, and obviously this
is gonna change, right, as they add different, more
types of nodes when, when different things make sense.
Um, but beyond that, right, you've got to back
up your VMs. And so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna kind of compare
how you back up VMs and EVS
on VSAN,
and then how it would work if you're leveraging FSX
RTP. So
here's a backup, right? You have a VSAN,
you have uh an a current image, you have
a VM and you wanna do a backup of that VM.
So you need to bring in some type of external backup
service to, to, to do the backup.
And so what that's gonna do is it's gonna take that
uh VMware snapshot, right?
And then that VMware snapshot has to be transferred.
Now, when you think about this,
this is putting a load on your
ESXI host, right? Having to do this work.
So you gotta think about,
are these big VMs? Can I do this in a certain SLA
in a certain window, right? When I'm, when I'm
off of, of. Production, you know,
key hours, right? So you gotta just keep all those
things in mind.
And then, so, you know, this can be a, it
can be a slow backup process. It depends on the size, it depends on what all
you have set up there. But to me, the other
important part here is that there's a VMware snapshot that's
taken. That's to have a VM consistent image,
right? The existence of that VM
consistent image, right,
has a performance penalty. And that's because as
future rights come in,
it has to keep track of the delta
with the current snapshot.
That has been shown to have a performance
impact. There's blogs out there about it, right? And a lot of the
things that try to correct it are basically by removing
snapshots. So then are you messing with your SLA?
Um, so, so you have to keep that in mind. So, you
know, it's more of a management difficulty. You have a, a,
uh, another backup service, you got to make sure that, you know, it's
not affecting your, your ESXI workloads.
And, um, so you're just adding a, a
bit of complexity to your overall backup
process. Now, let's compare that
with doing your backups if you're running,
uh, your data stores on
FSX for ONTAP instead of on,
on VSAN.
So we still have this current image, right?
The, the main thing is we're gonna set up a separate FSX
RONTAP system just to, to house
the backups.
Now the good thing about this separate system is that we
can scale it down, right? We don't need a large
throughput on it, right? So you'll pay less for throughput. We're
gonna put a, put a pretty minimal SSD
tier, like 90, you know, 5%
of the data will be sitting on the object
tier. And then you basically are going
to be doing where you're gonna still take
that VMware snapshot. Um, and that's
if you need a VM consistent image. Um.
Not, uh, on-prem. I've, I've talked to multiple people
who say, on-prem, lots of times, we
just need crash consistent. We don't even need a
VM consistent image. But for
this, this exercise, right, it depends on the
application, right? But for this exercise, we're gonna say,
hey, OK, we're doing the same thing, right? We're gonna take
a, a VMware snapshot.
Um, then we leverage that, you know,
that superpower of ONTA was that instantaneous
snapshot.
Um, and that just, you know, happens instantaneously. And
once you've done that,
here's the key, is that you can remove that VMware snapshot,
right? So now you're no longer gonna be having that
performance penalty. Now we also use,
um, that other
technology, SnapMirror, which is snapshot-based.
And it keeps that data d-duped and
compressed in transit.
So you're, so you're able to move the data and do
the backups faster, um, by leveraging
that same thing. The other main thing to, to, to
look, look at this. Picture?
Is this affecting your ESXi hosts? No. It's
at the storage layer, right? It's doing this, this replication
at the storage layer. So you're offloading
that to the storage layer and not affecting your ESXi
hosts. That's another big advantage.
So, you know, so this is giving you that faster backup
process. That snapshot was, the VMware snapshot
was deleted instantaneously. So that's zero
performance impact. And then a minimal
storage overhead because we have the, the data d-upped
and compressed, and we also move it d-upped and
compressed.
So that's the comparison of those two.
Now let's look at um how we
can operate the same way on-premises
as we do in the cloud. Um, and so for this
particular scenario, this is obviously talking about having on-Tap
on-prem, right? So we have ONTAP on-prem
and we have a data store.
Well, so when we set up our, you
know, EBS environment,
we can set up that data store. the same way. And it's just
giving you consistency. So having that
consistency, right, helps with discovery
and planning, right? And say, hey, however I'm
setting this up in here, whatever tools I'm using,
whatever automation, whatever, you know, maybe
playbooks I have for setting up my data stores
and managing those, I can do that
the exact same way in the cloud.
Avoid rewriting applications,
because, you know, this is an EBS, right? You can take an exact
image. It could be a very old image, right? And it might
not be one that's supported anymore, right? And
so you don't have to rewrite anything. You bring it up
into the cloud, you operate it in exactly the same
way. Um, and then you have
a simple and safe migration. Again, that same SnapMirror
I just talked about, right? You're gonna move the data
deep and compress a very easy way.
You take your data store on-prem, you just SnapMirror it up to the
cloud.
Um, and so you're really getting the full interoperability,
right? All those, you know, NSX managers, vSphere
clients, if you had any plug-ins to your vSphere
client, right, you can bring those up as well.
So you really are operating the same way if you had any,
you know, automations, those work the same way. Your playbooks
all work the same way.
But we're also preserving enterprise grade capabilities.
Things like, I mentioned Flex clones
before. So NetApp has a,
uh, technology along with VMware
called VAAI which offloads
certain um actions to the storage
layer, um, to help you operate faster.
And one of those is if you create a VM from
a template.
Um, you can leverage NetApp's Flex
clone technology, right, was that instantaneous copy
only storing the delta blocks. And so you can
spin up VMs much faster with
much less overhead by leveraging that
technology as well.
Also, maybe you had Snaplock, right? Maybe you
had that on-prem and you wanted to take that same level
of protection into the cloud.
So you're getting that consistent operational experience
on both sides.
All right, so now this gets us to uh
one that I'm really excited about, um, a disaster recovery
scenario that we have um with FSX for
OnTA, um, in this type of environment. Now
again, this is talking about on tap to
on tap, right? You have something on-prem,
uh, a data center running, that's running on vSphere.
Um, and you want to set up a disaster recovery
in the cloud. So what you can do is set a minimal
EVS cluster, right, that's deployed, um,
with it, and you would also keep a minimal FSXRWNTA
footprint.
So when you're doing this, right, you're gonna
replicate data up and most of that data
is going to be going into the capacity tier. You're gonna have a very
thin SSD tier, and you're gonna have just those 4
ESXI hosts, you know, kind of like a pilot light, right? This,
but right now, the 4 ESXI hosts is like the
minimum. Um. And that's tied to VCF
5.2.1. So that could change in the future, but right
now that's, that's the minimum. So, so we really have
a really minimal footprint.
Most of the data is going into the object
tier, and we only have 4 ESXi
hosts. So,
now what happens is, hey, a disaster
occurs. Um,
what you can then do is expand
the number, like now I'm gonna go production on this
side, right? I'm gonna need some more,
uh, compute, right? So I'm gonna add 4
additional ESXi hosts.
So I'm gonna scale up the SXI and
what I'm also gonna do is scale up the storage.
I'm gonna change the throughput on the FSX for
ONTAP system from maybe a 512
or 128, and I'm gonna put it to a 1
gig or a 2 gig SKU,
right? And so you're gonna meet the production workload, but
you weren't paying for that the whole time, right? That's really the beauty
of this is you only bring it up as you need. Now,
obviously, with this type of scenario You have to figure out
what are your SLAs, right?
Does this fit within your company's SLAs, right?
To have, because it will take some time, right,
to bring up additional ESXI
hosts, right? It will take some time
to, um, change the throughput, and
it's, you know, only like 30 some minutes, right, of your, of
your FSX VONTAP system. But there is, you know, an
impact there. So you just got to take all of that into account.
Um, and here's the other nice thing, right? Is that,
OK, we failed over, we're operating in the cloud,
and now
we're, you know, we've, we've corrected things and
now we want to go back to where we were before.
So you start replicating your data back all this
and using that SnapMirror technology, de-dupe and compressed,
the data, you know, very minimal footprint coming back,
um, when you do the replication back.
I mean, you scale down that EBS cluster, you no longer
need 4,
you know, 8 ESXI hosts, right? So you
can scale that, that back down to the minimum.
And here's the really cool thing, is that this
was a feature that's been asked about for a long time for FSXOTA,
and that was the ability to do
SSD,
well, shrink, or I think it's called SSD decrease.
But now, once you've done that,
you have to like at first evacuate the data up
into the capacity tier. But once that, the
data's been moved to the capacity tier, you can then shrink
down that SSD so this is not being used
anymore and really keep that minimum footprint.
Then you re-establish your, your
original snap relationship and you're back to this very
low level, right?
Had just what you need available for you at the
time. Um,
so, you know, obviously.
Disaster recovery can be more complex than what it was,
right, in that slide. There's a lot to do to
actually fail over, right? Complete working
environments on, uh,
you know, vSphere environment from one to the other.
So NetApp has a tool called NetApp Disaster Recovery
that helps you plan and manage and automate
that. And so it's not only doing the storage, it's
doing the storage with SnapMirror. And this is, this is
a tool only for OnTap to On-Tap.
And so, but it's, it's, you know, it's also,
um, failing over storage. Compute
and networking all together, right? And it has
plans for doing that. The other really cool feature
that it has, it has the ability to do
DR testing. And when it does the DR
testing, what it does is it leverages that
same Flex clone technology,
where when you fail over, it takes a Flex clone
and all the new data is being written on the Flex clone.
And again, it was an instantaneous copy of your data,
and only new deltas are being written.
Once that DR test is over.
You just delete the Flex clone and you're back to exactly
where you were before.
Um, so this is a tool that's, that was built for
this. Um, and since it's on tap to OnTap
is offered at a very competitive price
point, a lot of these tools will
charge per VM. This charges per storage,
and it charges it
at a very reasonable rate. Um, and it saves
you typically around 80% compared to other,
uh, disaster recovery tools that are out there in the market.
Um, if you're interested in it, um, just, you know, look up
NetApp disaster recovery, and there's a 30-day
free trial as well.
OK. So now switching gears
just a little bit, I'm gonna hop over to
uh Workload Factory.
So Workload Factory is a tool
that was developed, um, with kind of, uh, uh,
you know, ADS and NetApp together came up with this
plan for how do we want to set up a tool
that will allow you to
Optimize and use storage best practices across
multiple workloads where FSX ONTAP is
being used, right? And so this tool
works for
SQL workloads, um,
Oracle workloads,
uh, AI, right? It does a, a
plethora of different things. And it does it from planning
to making sure you stay well architected across
those different workloads, because things drift over time.
But in this particular case, right, we're talking about
what it's currently doing for VMware workloads.
And, um, for what it's doing right now is it basically
has some planning stuff, and it has this TCO calculator,
which I'm gonna show in a minute. And it has a way to make
sure that when you deploy your data stores, they're
gonna be leveraged by EBS that it does it
um with the optimal configurations.
So. I'm gonna start with the TCO
calculator. And for this TCO calculator,
basically, it's, it's just a really easy
tool. It's really convenient and nice to
use that will show you, you know,
different, uh, estimate the total cost of ownership
with different deployment scenarios that
you can put in there and identify cost
optimizations. I mean, obviously all
this data could
be figured out by the ADOS tools as well,
right? ADBS has pricing calculators, but it gets
a bit complex and this is a really easy
UI that can show it to you very quickly.
So I have a little uh demo on this one.
So at the very top here we have um console.
uh workloads.net.com. Anybody can go
here. It's free, right? Um,
and then you go into Explore savings. And so
at this point, what you're gonna basically be doing is putting into
the tool.
Hey, what am I looking at my EBS deployment
to be, right? What, how many, how much CPUs
do I need?
How many, um, what's my memory footprint?
What's my storage? And we give you these really convenient
sliders, right, to move that
information back and forth.
And as you're doing that over on the right-hand side,
right, you can see
what's my total cost gonna be? What's my total cost
for just doing EVS with this particular configuration
or, or EVS plus FSX
for ONTAP, like how can we potentially save you money there?
Obviously gonna change depending on your, your, your footprints.
And then also we're saying is that this is the um
1 year, 3-year or on-demand
for the cost of those I4I metal.
Now, obviously,
as more different instance types comes out, we'll be
adjusting this. Then it's gonna show you, hey,
this is what my FSX4ONTAP deployment is. This
is what we expect to save
from a,
you know, a data uh efficiency standpoint.
And then this is the exact cost that you would pay for the
FSX for ONTAP system.
Um, what's also really nice, right, I was gonna
show you that cost, is that over on the right, it
shows you, hey,
here are how many I4ite instances
I need to match that, those parameters,
but how many do I need that were just for storage,
right? And so it's gonna easily show you,
hey, I, I needed some of these ESXi
hosts just for storage. And it's also gonna lay out
all the costs, cause there are multiple cost
components to EDS.
There's the um.
The just the, the there's a VPC, um,
the EBS control plane, right, that you also had
to pay for. You also had to pay for the route server. So there's
a few other, they're not the major components. The I4I
metal, right, is the main one, but there are
some other components. So it's gonna take all of that stuff
into account and give you that total cost of ownership
and say, does it make sense to add FSXONTAP
or does it not make sense? And that's just purely
from a pure cost perspective.
So that's, that's the, the calculator. Again, well,
you can definitely, uh, log into it. I, I'll show a QR
code in just a minute.
The other, uh, main tool that we have right now
is, you know, once you determine, hey, I want to
use FSX for RONTAP,
here's my, here's what I was kind of planning to do for it.
Now I want to actually do the deployment of it. So it's gonna
deploy your FSX for ONTAP
system. It's gonna deploy the data storage, it's
gonna set them up with best practices. You can actually
even tie it into your EBS environment.
And have it set,
like if you're doing NFS for example, and that's what this one
supports currently, it might, it might add others later.
For right now, it'll set the right timing
values. It'll set in connect values,
right? So it's gonna do everything for, for best
practices.
And so this is the QR code.
Feel free to take a picture of this, and this will take you to
that calculator. It's 100% free, as
I said before.
Log in there. And actually, at the very top of that calculator
is a little email
that me and a couple other people from my team will
get. So if you start using it and you have any
questions, feel free to reach out to us.
So the key takeaways today, right, um, is
that this is bringing control and
consistency. Like when you bring your EVS environment
in here,
you are getting complete control of your
VCF environment, right? And if you're
leveraging FSX for ONTAP, right, you're having
that same consistency. If you're using,
uh, you know, ONTAP in the, on-prem, you're
getting that same way in the cloud.
We're bringing all those enterprise grade capabilities,
the deduplication, compression.
The ability to do snapshots,
the ability to do autonomous ransomware protection, right?
All of those types of capabilities are also being
brought into the cloud. And then, of course,
you know, what people really care about,
cost savings, right? So we're able
to decouple that compute and storage as
well as apply all those efficiencies, and
that's gonna really help you keep uh your,
your cost uh to as low as
possible for your EBS deployments.
And
with that, I'll say thank you. Please, um, complete
that session survey in the mobile app.
Um, and I'll stay around here, um, for any
questions. I'll just be right down here, I'd be happy to, to, to
talk with anybody about anything around this, this topic.
Thank you so much. I appreciate it.